Hi, I am Naomi and I am very excited to show you...
...the world's greatest attractions.
Imagine an army over 8,000 strong, built by men for conquest after death.
That is what you will see if you travel to visit the Terracotta Army.
This enormous force rests in hundreds of ranks,...
...no two soldiers exactly the same.
Besides the infantry, the army consists of hundreds of cavalry and chariots.
The first Emperor of China, Qin Shi Huang,...
...ordained its construction in roughly 210 B.C.
The Terracotta Army was supposed to continue...
...the Emperor's conquest in the afterlife.
The army is only one part of an enormous grave complex.
Archaeologists are still excavating the site,...
...but there are areas that are open to visitors.
Thank you for watching our travel video series.
See you next time.